don't bring anyone love into this
there's two mommies and one jeans that's
how it goes again if you haven't seen it
it's called machines with Tim and it's
on Netflix right now I actually had this
song in my head over the weekend a lot
of no I a lot it's not a bad song I feel
like it's not that bad I mean it can
take some work it needs work but it's
not bad it's pretty amazing yeah like I
feel like if the right band took it and
actually reworked it it would be very
good well we have a number of people
that have reworked it oh my god it's
pretty exciting we also have this email
listen to the latest episode of my way
to work you guys suck I'm walking out my
office and machines within machines
within is stuck in my head trying to
focus at my computer machine it's like
that juggle who tapped into something
inside of me mega all right Chris cuz I
was laying in bed last night and you
were supposed to be giving me head
scratches which were inferior because I
woke up but my hair was not tangled and
but the whole now I was going machines
with you know an old fantasy about I had
this and you know I know I do a lot of
like you know I do a lot of thinking you
know when I take like 10 or 12 benadryl
no but I'll come up with jokes and stuff
in the shower I always thinking this
yeah yeah and I was this weekend I mean
I was on the road and I was doing shows
and then I was like machines boy I was
like we should fly that guy out bring
him to like a friend's studio yeah and
like have a real producer friend of mine
lay a beat and like film it that had
this dude job B and then one of my good
friends who you know is a music video
director yeah yes yes a video that was
that would kind of be the most amazing
thing to ever happen to this man yeah I
think we should work on you know let's
find him does anyone know who he is
let's find him do you have any contact
yeah does anyone have contact for
machines with in guy because I think
that could be I think we need to make
this happen we need to fly in LA
and we need to treat him like a star and
yet his career doing machines within you
know I think we could really do
something special with that I think but
in the meantime some of our you know we
are know a lot of podcasts will claim
you know their this and that there are
no there's no podcasts in the world it
has a better a library and a better
musically inclined base than we do we
have yeah
some of the songs you know the songs
that have come out of this show some of
them are incredible like there's really
talented people making music machines
with machines with it all right so it's
not a bad song I got a slight
distraction but happen to something
there listen so here's just a few but
you just let me know let's see this is a
this is machines within featuring Charo
by DJ socks on the track okay all right
dude our listeners are so talented
[Music]
it's a different approach because here's
the thing when I hear I hear
interesting that you say needs to go
that way
but so this was just someone's take on a
slow this is kind of an it's a chiller
this is chiller bro so I'm kind of
scarier vibe yeah because it had like an
airy like horror movie quality to kind
of 1610 I feel like these machines could
have been in the Sicario movie in -
right yeah right coming up on the house
machines but
take like 16 benadryl sitting up the old
shit song Halloween Street Street
[Music]
but she's really good I mean so good I
should have done this to to remind
people but like this is what they're
working on
yeah trying to see my song trying to see
my song
okay here we go here we go okay I have
another beatdown for you I try to
practice practice my own song this is my
introduction to my song yeah coming out
you know here we go I'll sing it shoots
were thin machines they got a gun and
God against all the going up and
terminating their gun
yeah machines but this thing's worth it
trying to rank my rep trying to make my
rep Cheung dr. cymet well Charlie talk
to someone full machines width in
machines worth this hearing hearing on
the street I don't give a f--- the
haters all the haters just need a
producer
[Music]
good shit yeah DJ socks on the track man
yeah very interesting take on it very
interesting take on it it's awesome I
applaud you I mean I can't believe you
that's amazing it's amazing what people
can do so this is machines within I'm
gonna up here by Equus yeah ok so this
is another version of machines within
yeah different take and yeah just you
know what do you like mastodons it's
also kind of this killer vibe right
[Music]
[Applause]
again what's t16 text the gun I don't
know what he's doing
genes within machines so this is must
genes within genes listening by Benny
Harper listening again if if you need a
reminder but we're going off of here
it's just just she's with them machines
with it that's it that's all these guys
had to work with maze here we go
miss jeans with it
16:16
suits with she's with him she's with
this is we're on the right track
[Music]
- sirs -
I don't think it's bad
[Music]
in those streets
yeah
[Music]
yeah pretty good man you know that we
have your mom's house we have fans that
are actual real like famous musicians
that listen to this yeah we have a few I
would I challenge those guys if anyone's
got some free time I would love to see
someone do machines with machines with
it man
I was really good yeah I feel like
Metallica if they could cover it would
be you know what I mean oh yeah I mean
they could no I feel like they could
come out with a completely unexpected
and really dope actually like oh that's
kind of deep and like yeah what is oh
yeah I do sign what the man you
internalize the societal structures
whatever the fuck that means
sure a lot going on
[Music]